have you ever been in a situation where
you're like
i feel like i'm not allowed to lose my
temper like that
i feel like i'm not allowed to get
emotional i feel like if a guy gets
emotional he's like passionate and
intense and he's good at his job but if
i get emotional i'm like a crazy bitch
yeah but again that i don't i also think
when a guy does it that he's
my i am a big my i came up with my
father
saying basically like never let him see
you sweat my i never saw my dad get
angry he never got angry in argument he
always was very soft-spoken
my brother and i would know if my dad
was mad it was because we could barely
hear him
i mean that was what was scary to us so
to me somebody flying off the handle and
being angry man or woman
they just lost they lost their shit
literally
and you know i have opposing counsels
that will you know say
make cutting remarks say mean things
that doesn't help them i
see what judges are able to see
and i can tell that that's not helping
but people can't help themselves and
that's what you don't want
in a representative or a lawyer you want
someone who's able to
really really hold your cards close to
your chest
make the best argument that they can for
you we were talking a little bit before
about the tattoo
that had less to do with like my boss
feeling like a tattoo was you know
female or racy i mean we literally i
would wear glasses
and i didn't need glasses but i wanted
to look older and i wanted a little to
look more serious yeah
it's about you know and i had guys that
i went to law school with that had nose
rings or ponytails and the
teachers said look you never know what
your judge is going to be thinking so
you want to take yourself kind of out of
the equation can you be fashionable
can you look attractive yes but you want
it to be about the case that you're
making for your client
and your client also by the same token i
have had to take clients
we m our offices in century city over to
the westfield mall
buy them a suit because they're punk
rockers and they like have tattoos and a
torn t-shirt and i'm like dude
let's go i mean you know you have to
dress accordingly because the law
is something where you are putting your
best face forward yes
whether you want to have custody of your
kids pay less money people always say
what do i wear
well if you're going in and you're
asking for spousal support because
you've been out of the workforce for so
many years
don't wear valentino huh blue suit you
know
tie on the column you don't have to wear
a costume yeah yeah yeah wearing your
flashiest with your air masks
wear a wedding dress right that's when
you should wear it
when am i going to wear this again or
wrap yourself you know people like
to show up just people always say like
what do i do with this wedding dress
wear to your divorce
trial this diet blast me on an episode
um viewers reminded me of something like
you know we talk a lot on this podcast
as someone that
talks a lot uh and has a very
adversarial relationship with
talking um because it's like what i do
for a living but when women do it too
much it's annoying and like
someone put a dick in her mouth it's
like i i feel like there's a
i have a very um tight tight leash in
terms of
when i'm she's powerful she's strong now
she's annoying and crazy and obnoxious
and
a nag and shrill and whatever um but
it it is such a helpful reminder i think
at this time
when women want to be like and i'm going
to fucking say what i think and i'm
gonna be outspoken or just in general
the sort of
the younger people that i work with are
like i'm gonna say my feelings all the
time and i want to tell them like
yes being authentic great saying what
you feel
great but the real power is
shutting the fuck up measuring twice
cutting once
and when you speak saying something
incisive
uh clear cogent and then people actually
fucking listen when you talk
yeah and when you speak softly people
also often lean in to hear what you're
saying instead of
leaning back because you're yelling or
being what could be perceived as
offensive
literally the art of seduction 101 it's
like
we had robert greene on the podcast to
talk about all that um which reminds me
of i did used to date a guy that used
that in a very manipulative way where
um when we would get in fights if i lost
my temper he would start talking quieter
and quieter
he'd be like why are you why are you
yelling like
you're like why are you freaking out
okay you're like i'm sorry what yeah so
then i'm like what
yeah and then whatever you do sounds so
loud it was like his way of making me
crazier than i was
like why are you yelling i'm not yelling
like it's just like no it seems like i'm
yelling because you're
whispering um that is uh
that one didn't work um but uh but yeah
i just
i just think that that is something that
i as someone that's been fascinated with
you and has watched you for a long time
and as
i'm trying to figure out what being
powerful looks like
what it sounds like i got the wrong
programming
right i thought it was like loud
aggressive you have to talk the most
say the most in the meeting be the
loudest
and it's taken me so long to realize
that it's not true power
it's it's a it's like a huge lesson yeah
that i feel like
you know even with social media and
posting it's like
more is not always right sometimes and
you know
and then what do you ever want to this
is like a totally geek
law question do you want to go first
no not usually how do you get the who
decides that
if you file the motion then you are
usually the one that's going for us
because you're the moving party
so you present first right so i want
this
and so i'm gonna make my you know and
then the other person says well i don't
want to give you this and so it's this
so
i mean it depends and most of the time
you know who's going to go first but
once in a while
somebody will like will position or
whatever i don't really care either way
i mean it also depends on how long the
trial is if you if you're going to go
first and then there's not going to be
another hearing for a month then
that's not an advantage because you want
to be the one that the judge remembers
yeah yeah you're doing it all in one day
i mean i don't care